[Música]
economía en directo américa de france 24
ya está conmigo nuevamente en el estudio
jorge hurtado para este último bloque
económico del día y también de la semana
jorge vamos a darle seguimiento al
conflicto en europa del este más allá
del tema político que se discute también
la dependencia del gas ruso así es que
la comisión europea ya anunció que está
en búsqueda de nuevas alianzas
estratégicas para su reserva energética
y también para la compra
en común de este bloque así lo dijo
úrsula von der leyen quien es presidente
de la comisión europea
a un diario francés la funcionaria
aseguró que el bloque se prepara frente
a una falta de suministro de gas ruso
cuyos precios aumentaron en el contexto
de la atención geopolítica entre rusia y
ucrania von der leyen dijo que no
descartó utilizar el gasoducto nord
stream 2 que conecta rusia con alemania
por el mar báltico como parte de las
sanciones en caso de que moscú
intervenga a ucrania en la actualidad
raúl cerca del 40% del gas que se
consume en la unión europea procede de
rusia la comisión europea acaba de
lanzar una alianza energética
estratégica con el presidente
estadounidense
von der leyen comentó que ya buscan
nuevos proveedores como noruega qatar
azerbaiyán y egipto jorge los precios
mundiales de petróleo también continúan
al alza así es y bueno esto sumado a la
atención que ya se vive en europa del
este con el conflicto en medio oriente
ahora se le agrega un nuevo elemento el
clima gélido en varias zonas de eeuu que
dispara los precios este viernes el
crudo brent o con los 92 35 dólares por
barril esto luego de subir 116 dólares
el jueves por su parte el crudo
estadounidense west texas llegó a los 91
56 tras haber ganado 2 dólares el día
anterior este último se ubica por encima
de los 90 dólares por primera vez desde
el 6 de octubre de 2014 las dos
referencias mundiales se encaminan a la
séptima ganancia semanal consecutiva el
alza fue motivada por una ráfaga de en
el ártico que pasa por texas se
interrumpió parte de la producción de
petróleo en la cuenca térmica de allí se
extrae el 40 por ciento del petróleo
producido en eeuu algunos analistas raúl
afirman que la recuperación de la
demanda está superando a la oferta y los
mercados del petróleo son cada vez más
vulnerables a este tipo de
interrupciones jorge y también el banco
de noriega tendrá un nuevo director de
quién se trata así es se trata del
actual secretario de la otan gene
stoltenberg que se convertirá en
presidente del banco de noruega a
finales de este año el nombramiento
llama la atención en el contexto de
tensión entre occidente y rusia por la
crisis ucraniana el funcionario con
formación académica se presentó como
candidato por solicitud del ministerio
de finanzas de noruega que destacó su
compromiso social y capacidad de gestión
en noruega la decisión ha sido
controversial por los vínculos del
funcionario con el gobierno que dirige
el partido laborista stoltenberg
dirigido este partido entre 2012 y 2014
ahora deberá decidir sobre la política
monetaria de noruega así como manejar su
fondo soberano que a propósito es el más
grande del mundo bueno jorge me en
países bajos como lo estábamos avanzando
se discutirá una norma que obligará a
los inversionistas de viviendas a
recibir cuatro años cuando se compre una
casa así amsterdam específicamente
esperan que en abril se introduzca la
obligación de residir en la vivienda
durante los primeros cuatro años
posteriores a la compra esto para
aquellos que adquieran una propiedad con
un valor oficial de hasta 512 mil euros
según las autoridades una de cada tres
viviendas son propiedad de inversores
privados y la iniciativa busca que los
compradores de primera vivienda y las
personas de ingresos medios tengan más
posibilidades de adquirir una casa la
medida afectará a seis de cada diez
viviendas de propiedades existentes en
amsterdam así como al sector
inmobiliario como tal por ejemplo
algunos inversionistas ya no podrán
comprar casas para luego rentar las a un
precio más alto aunque se aplicarán
algunas restricciones 'jorge para ya a
finalizar que nuestra entonces como
cifra el día los juegos olímpicos de
toque 2020 costaron 13 mil 600 millones
de dólares 5 mil 900 millones de ellos
fueron aportados por el comité
organizador y 7 mil 700 por las
administraciones públicas los
organizadores dijeron que pese a las
inversiones que tuvieron que hacer extra
por el cómic 19 el gasto final estuvo
por debajo de los 15 mil 400 millones de
dólares que se calculaban antes de
empezar los juegos jorge gracias
entonces por toda la información
económica feliz fin de semana nos vemos
el lunes con más información de economía
mundial vamos ahora a directo hasta
parís
[Música]